it's time for et's Kardashian ketchup  kicking it off with Courtney's 38th  birthday mom Kris Jenner shared a  collage for her eldest daughter while  sister Chloe posted an eclectic vid of  Courtney's finest moments Kim Kardashian  shared adorable family photos from  Easter weekend posing with husband Kanye  West and children north and Saint and  pendel Jenner says she's more of a  Jenner than a Kardashian in the May  issue of Harper's Bazaar Kendall says  quote I mean I'm a girl and I like being  a girl but I've just never been into it  like they have referring to her sisters  adding I think I get that from my dad  over the weekend Kendall sparked romance  rumors when she was spotted out with  ASAP Rocky at Coachella Music Festival  but she tells the mag there's nothing  serious happening in her personal life  quote I'm doing my thing I'm having fun  I'm being young then there's this Kylie  and Kim's cosmetic collaboration  [Music]  you